should we expect any more baby
announcements
on instagram in the video we have well
they didn't expect that to happen
you guys started following haim on
instagram
and my dream is for this trio of sisters
to collaborate with you guys a trio of
brothers
we have discussed time soon after 30
years
what does still keep you guys challenged
and inspired in doing this does it still
feel
like it did yeah it does you mean
besides each other
your new project against the world is
coming out
soon it's being released every month a
new song what kind of makes this album
special well i mean lots of things i
mean one of this whole idea of releasing
music in pieces
i mean it goes back almost a decade
we've been independent for a long time
and so we're
able to sort of think a little
differently about how we release things
because we get together and we say hey
what do we want to try
you can kind of dismantle what it means
to put out a record and
we thought man it's it's so it would be
so nice to have this more that sense of
a journey
where music is continuing to happen
there's another thing and we've
been a long time this is our seventh
studio album and our nine
thousand other hours yeah yeah we made a
lot of um
i think it's more and more important
that every song is
adding to that catalog and saying
something important you want to put the
spotlight on it for a minute and this
allows us to say
here's the first song and and look at it
and live with it and love on it and then
move to the next
[Music]
we just released a song called annaleigh
and it's you know it's very much it
feels like
hey we're going on a journey it's it's
very organic it's
uh it's definitely very welcoming it's
you know upbeat as the songs go on you
know they get richer they get a little
heavier
different flavors and it is going to be
cool to see just to see what it's like
to have people
slowly see this album build like right
in front of
uh your eyes so be a new experience what
made it the right song to come out
first to really launch this project yeah
so
is anally is an interesting song for
this project because i think
we felt like it was very inviting it
also we've done a lot of different
sounds on our records this is maybe
something we've never showed about
ourselves i mean it's leading with my
voice which is something that's true to
our singles
i noticed that in the video i was like
so much zach happening right now
maybe too much that i talk attack
i don't really like the message of the
song i think um
the world has felt really kind of
intense and at odds with each other
and this song is all about grace so it's
about the name and elite which means
uh god's grace how does the song compare
to the rest of the album what's kind of
the vibe
the rest of the round
you should say you should say most good
songs don't sound like each other
so anna lee is very rootsy it has those
false assignments
it's organic and rhythmic it feels
almost like a train
kind of the drums pushing you along uh
the next song is called don't ever
change
um so that'll come out in june and it's
very like
power pop garage rock rick nielsen from
a cheap trip plays on it
yeah goes somewhere completely different
yeah it looks different it sounds
yeah the third song that we're planning
to release is called only love
and uh it's very gospel and very
like it's kind of rootsy a little bit
like italy but in a very different way
as people discover these songs i think
you'll see that
a lot of these songs touch on taking on
challenges kind of coming through
hardships and looking for hope through
you know sort of through that
darkness and and um musically you see
those you know their full thoughts i
think something else that's gonna be fun
are all the live shows that you guys
announced you're going to be playing
this album along with a classic
album is it still fun to play the older
stuff is it still fun to play
where's the love bop yeah it's crazy we
look forward to that because it
it just gives you this chance to revisit
where you come from
is it still fun absolutely i mean we
have a great job
last time i expect playing music uh
and having people that really love what
you do
in the room with you that that does not
suck you guys also have a 2022
world tour planned how will it actually
be able to play music
live again we don't know
we've forgotten how to play a new
experience it's like learning
people's hands again i'm gonna i've been
practicing hugging
trying to remember what that feels like
whenever we you know hug each other
again
yeah i think i just like to put it out
there now free hugs festival guys
spring of 2022 we'll start the world
tour and
that just honestly it probably feels
like a kid
thinking about christmas you know for us
that's what we live for
traveling around meeting people this
this ability to create
those intangibles that happen when
strangers get in a room and sing along
together
you know there's something i think
really important about that
just for the soul of the world yeah
absolutely just
to see each other together sharing these
moments um
and so we're we're excited we'll be you
know australia europe us
oh south not in latin america
between the three of you you have 15
children which is incredible truly
two people how has
fatherhood influenced the type of music
that you guys are making
how does fatherhood not end yeah that's
really fair
i think inevitably your experiences
definitely
get into the way you write songs and
your conclusions and these these
mini stories uh that we write that we
call songs
i think the other thing is it becomes
more important
that idea of a little bit what's the
legacy you're leaving as you know you're
leaving that
to your kitchen you're talking to your
kids through the art you make
and so it just becomes just that much
more important
that you're kind of speaking from the
heart but i
do agree that that you you start kind of
strongly considering
what kind of legacy you're you're
leaving yeah not just not just to your
fans not just to the world but but to
your kid
our kids are starting to get old enough
that they're coming out on their own
solo like my son shepard coming out and
hanging out for a couple weeks on the
road
and going to places and experiencing
those things now you're doing it as dad
you know and you have the memory of
being the kid
and it flips everything on its head i'm
actually just trying
to train a guitar tech so i don't have
to paint
i feel like women always get asked this
so i'm going to ask you guys this
how do you find the time to balance the
recording the touring
the family life and the home life and
all of that
it's a great question and it's so true
that the balance
is almost impossible to find i'm
grateful that we started so young
because as we've all begun to have
bigger and bigger families
you can't prioritize the music over to
your kids and the legacy that that you
have to leave with them of being a dad
and so as you go into making music you
really need to rely more on instinct
and hope that over the years you've been
playing you've developed enough instinct
to work faster and to speak clearer
because
you really do have to put them as the
number one thing they're a precious
commodity
yeah i think too i mean part of the
great training of being on
the road and doing what we've done is
you know chaos
is normal normal
so having kids having families having
big different relationships different
different ages i mean
it's never all perfectly lined up but
you're trying and you you know
you first of all we should not skip over
you marry amazing women oh my gosh and
they are incredible like if that wasn't
if you didn't have that that trust and
that confidence so that's really where
it's just partnership
then no way you could be you know here
but i think it's important
to not to not underplay being a dad and
being a father like i think our whole
culture
i mean the truth is there's so much you
know
lack of really celebrating women in our
you know in society like women are the
most incredible things they tie us all
together but as
as dads too we we need to i think also
it's important to say how important
being a dad so you're just trying to
you're trying to be the example you
want for them to see i mean taylor you
have seven kids zach
you have five isaac three should we
expect
any more baby announcements on instagram
well they didn't expect that to happen
now so
i don't know you know we're not spraying
anything my wife looked at me the other
day said i think i'm done
we've all been incredibly blessed with
amazing kids and amazing
families so i've always taken it one at
a time that led us to seven
so i'm just gonna hold right
my youngest is seven years old so i
don't i don't i don't think we're
starting over anytime soon yeah you
think okay
i'm thinking of getting there's a high
likelihood of another dog
taylor and zach i mean you guys do have
newborns at home
quincy maybelline are you guys sleeping
right now
how is that going no i'm not really
sleeping
we also have a two-year-old so yeah you
guys yeah the two-year-old
double barrel oh yeah i woke up today
with like he had a nunchuck
she was like hey it's cool please don't
do that that way
i will say i i did forget how much
you do start over with every child and
that's probably the beauty of parent
amnesia
you love them so much that you go let's
do it again and then you go wow this is
hard
why did i do that but uh he's awesome
not a whole lot of sleep but my wife
gives me some grace in the evenings but
usually hands him to me in the morning
and says wake up
go i did notice though you guys started
following heim
on instagram and my dream is for this
trio of sisters to collaborate with you
guys a trio of brothers
and make that idea magic have you ever
talked to them about this
we actually have we have we have
discussed time sign
actually if i remember correctly estee
was the one who texted that particular
girl so essie and i have the same
birthday
though every when i have a birthday a
lot of times they'll be like hey i'm
worth it
and actually the interesting thing about
them and us is
that when you put the sisters and the
brothers together in the combo of kind
of primary instrument
it makes it worse yeah because you don't
have a baseball card
i mean obviously you guys have talked
about this at length you all have
wonderful hair
when could we expect this song like is
this a serious conversation or more of
like a joke
it is more germinating idea that has
been thrown around between us we've hung
out a few times and they're super
super fun great we love their stuff yeah
they've been very complimentary about us
over the years so i think the concept
makes it's like yes this would be kind
of ridiculous but there is no concrete
there's no concrete plan just just that
kind of what would happen
isaac i think you touched on this a
little bit ago but hanson
formed in 1992 next year marks 30 years
which is
insane and now i feel very old
sorry to do that to you
what what will you guys do to celebrate
are you talking about doing something
special i think that we've got a couple
crazy ideas of
our slaves and we're trying to decide
which one
or ones to do more than anything we want
to connect we just want to be
connecting with those who have stuck
with us followed us come to shows
after 30 years what does still keep you
guys
challenged and inspired in doing this
does it still feel like it did it just
you mean besides each other it doesn't
feel the same it feels different it
feels
in some cases certain things that are
really important we're really important
are less important
new things are important but i do know
for i know for everybody
like getting to do music getting to
write songs and share is like
you realize more than ever just how rare
and amazing that is
that we've been able to do it your kids
a lot of them are the ages that you were
when you did get into this
industry do you guys see yourselves in
them
what is that like for you i'm seeing
myself in them more and more
in a weird way especially my oldest son
who started playing guitar
i'm definitely seeing i'm seeing light
bulbs go off and
seeing like the processes that they i'm
imagining uh you know remembering
through them
what those seasons were like to that
point too i've been trying
my best to to uh harness
my inner uh diana hanson who's that's
dangerous because she was a real
go-getter for us
when we were first starting out time i
think that's the biggest thing giving
them the opportunities to really test
themselves
uh and and see where it goes are they
dating yet
any of them we're trying yesterday you
guys are like
well i'm just wondering taylor because
your oldest is 18 i think you were 20
when you got
married or had your first child so
could you go it's crossed my mind that's
why we're happy for the pandemic
you're not leaving this pandemic's going
for at least three more years
and you know i was pregnant for my 16
year old daughter who is like she's like
ready to go you know
from 10 she's like where are the keys no
you can't drive
so i have two that can drive 18 and 16.
yeah there's things that bruin and
they're they're definitely at that time
where that's becoming reality
um you've had the talk you know that
there's lots there's there's
awareness i love that zach is loving
this so much
oh i'm loving it the most oh it's great
to just sit here and not have to say
anything
i'm definitely in that moment and it's
cool going back to the whole 30-year
career thing none of you guys i mean
taylor you did do tinted windows
but none of you guys ever really
embarked on a solo
career like nick jonas perhaps
right why was that was that ever a
conversation between the three of you
everything is really particular at the
time this takes a lot of time
i mean uh there i mean honestly for
several things i mean for one
there was such a there was a really
desire to solidify being this group
you know because groups are so
especially when we first came out it was
such a desire to depict it as
super pop and maybe this is manufactured
because it's which we were so young
i think we all felt really strongly
about we're gonna we're gonna be this
band
it's gonna sort of beat the odds and you
know have this longevity and and really
and stick together yeah stay together i
feel like i'm supposed to announce
something right now you know like
i'm running for president me
and the rock that would be what a will
that would be to vote for
that would be i've got the hair he's got
the muscles you